[Musique]
claude amar est aspiré qu'un que la
bouille de sanaa creux d'une vague
l'aboiement de la mag mais c'est là que
l'eau salée est monté en pression elle
est envoyée à travers les membranes
osmose inverse puis l'eau potable qui en
résulta précieux et acheminé à la berge
avec la tiu soumaré
[Musique]
énormément de cachette pour des plus
petits poissons même l'ancrage 102
points d'attaché pour différentes haltes
corps ou potentiellement
certains animaux qu'il obtient au vu des
pièces des petits poissons des crabes
à 200% de lula est aspiré par la boue et
il ya peu près 25 pour ce qui est de
l'eau potable il est celle qui se
retrouvaient l'instant 25% ne se
retrouvent dans le 75 % quel est donc ce
à peu près 30% plus de concentration en
sel pour la logique était là bas
[Musique]
on ne rejette pas d'assumer rare sur
l'emploi se borde la plage où il ya très
peu de mouvements de l'eau en fait c'est
vraiment loin de la plage donc
généralement environ un kilo mais où
l'eau et la saumure qui réussit à se
placer beaucoup de mouvement et de
rythme écoulée les vagues mélange la
surnomme alors appuyé avait cours à
marie
[Musique]
on
la majorité de la population du monde
via - le sac normal peco alors que les
réseaux siens contient 250 fois plus
donc toutes les autres sources gic et
d'accessible d'eau potable donc ça
serait la source le jet d'eau potable
pour les populations fosse aux ours à
voir d'une façon durable contrairement à
ce qui se fait actuellement
[Musique]